c'est difficile à dire parce que ce sont
le peu de départements et peu de
sénateur mais enfin ce que l'on peut
constater globalement après les
résultats avant le premier tour même
s'il ya une dizaine de sénateurs élus
dès le premier tour
c'est que la tendance se confirme que la
droite est majoritaire dans les grands
électeurs gagné 2014 gagné 2015 et de
fait elle fait de bons scores parce
qu'elle a une base la deuxième tendance
qui se confirme pas c'est que nous c'est
un peu plus difficile mais on savait
donc que tout c'est de savoir combien
nous serons deux sénateurs à l'arrivée
le groupe socialiste pour l'instant ça
se passe pas si mal que ça mais nous
savions que nous perdrions des sièges
est bien évident et puis la troisième
c'est quand même la faible implantation
locale de la république en marche qui
fait qu' ils sont pour ces premiers
départements hausse que l'eau scrutin
uninominal à deux tours un peu à la
peine
vous savez on va attendre ce qui va se
passer au deuxième tour de ces premiers
départements ain
parce que le report des voix ce n'est
pas comme dans une élection classique
souvent l'élu connais bien le terrain
etc
et puis sur la proportionnelle on peut
avoir des surprises mais d immense
surprise dans un sens ou dans l'autre le
nombre de listes 9 10 11 12 listes c'est
un peu technique que je m'en excuse pour
les téléspectateurs fait que le quotient
électoral va être abaissé et pour deux
ou trois voix
on peut avoir qu'un sénateur socialiste
de plus aucun signe acteurs se disent de
moins et c'est pareil pour la droite
donc là vraiment on peut faire aucun
pronostic faut attendre le résultat
parce que les derniers sièges seront
vraiment un
un deux trois voix